brought to you by Dark Souls 3 pre-order
now to receive a free upgrade to the day
one edition it is Friday which means I
have five of this week's biggest stories
all ready to go to you hear something
this week System Shock three was
accidentally announced by jeff's to do
other side entertainment the developer
launched a countdown website which is
still going mind you but they also
mistakenly sent another page on the site
live which featured the system shock 3
logo other side entertainment was
founded by porn Europe who is also the
founder of Looking Glass Studios the
creator's of the original system shock
are the key figures at the studio
include joke fielder who previously
worked on bioshock infinite Rockstar
Games announced a new multiplayer mode
for GTA online called every bullet count
the description for the mode reads for
players go up against each other in a
confined space with a very limited
arsenal just one marksman pistol and two
bullets to take out three opponents
they'll need to resort to copy melee
attacks with their hatchets or machete
to make it out alive on top of that
players whose central too long will have
their position revealed the mode is
available now on xbox one ps4 and PC
premix took time out to explain why at
Final Fantasy 7 remake is coming out in
multiple parts producer Yoshinori Kitase
I told Famitsu one of the main reasons
why we haven't done the remake until now
is because it's a massive undertaking to
reconstruct final fantasy 7 from the
ground up with the current technology he
added that one installment was simply
not going to be enough to contain the HD
Final Fantasy 7 remake they intend on
making designer Tetsuya Nomura said one
installment would have led to a
condensed and inferior game adding I'm
sure everyone is anxious about the
schedule and we want everyone to get to
play the game as soon as possible to
drawing the line on that front is
another reason why we're taking this
approach
said approach read have revealed the
first images from The Witcher 3 next
expansion blood in the line the chair
new images show off the new region of
Tucson where girls will need to
investigate the ancient bloody secrets
of the otherwise peaceful promise the
expansion will offer up new year and
enemies as well as both new and
returning characters the expansion is
expected to offer us around 20 hours of
gameplay double that of the Wichita
raised last expansion lots of stone
finally a sports has suggested that set
of cracked intends to release cyberpunk
2077 next year when the game was
originally announced back in 2012 the
developer said they wouldn't be
discussing it until at least 20 17 now
that may not be the case as the source
has informed game reactor Germany that a
late 2016 launch is planned for the game
the source added that while the game is
only confirmed for PC at the moment a
ps4 and xbox one release is more than
likely let me know down in the comments
what you care about this week and if
you'll be playing to which agrees next
expansion this week on site we launched
our game of the year award you can head
to gamespot now to see our winners for
Nintendo and Sony console and stay tuned
for Xbox and PC fifth weekend that is
everything I have you this week as
always have yourself a lovely weekend
and I will catch you again online
you
you